le prochain un reportage vous préviens
est assez désespérant sur la nature
humaine vous allez voir que sur les bord
d'autoroute
nous jetons collectivement une tonne de
déchets au kilomètre dans certains cas
comme nous dit étudiants vous ne les
apercevez peut-être pas en voiture mais
les déchets qui jonchent les bordure des
autoroutes de la province sont
innombrables
souvent c'est dégueulasse qu'on chante
en partie du monsieur on n'a pas le
choix
ici sur le tour devait entre le tunnel
louis hippolyte lafontaine et
sainte-julie et travailleurs du sous
traitant est maire recueil l'équivalent
d'une tonne de déchets par kilomètre au
printemps le des pires secteur au québec
à 64 ans jocelyn tente de se faire à
l'idée que les comportements ne
changeront pas de sitôt oram en russe
les morceaux qui ont entaché apparaît
les morceaux à shalio les petits
morceaux et on mange quoi parce qu'on a
fourni à voir tout ce que mon jet
partager les bouteilles de bière
n'importe quoi des déchets des couches
on trouve de tout on trouve de tout et
parfois même les objets à sinusite et
une baignoire une cuvette ont déjà été
retrouvé dans un fossé pour nettoyer ici
les bordures de ses voix dans la
province étant dans la pelouse le
ministère des transports des bourses une
importante somme et on a un budget qui
est dédié à sa pour l'année 2013-2014 on
parle d'un peu moins de 5 millions de
dollars
et pourtant depuis des décennies il y à
une loi qui interdit de jeter quoi que
ce soit sur un chemin public
le nombre de contraventions de 100
dollars émise par la sûreté du québec
dans la province est passé de près de
300 il ya deux ans à 500 en 2013
mais le pire dans tout ça frappés le
plus c'est du monde qui nous jettent des
ordures quand on en ramasse on dirait
qu'il ira fleurir de nouveaux dans son
enveloppe ici mathieu dion à radio
canada boucherville